les partisans de la peine de mort moins
nombreux les hommes politiques partagées
entre leurs convictions et leurs
responsabilités le témoignage du
professeur jankelevitch l'aîné houleuse
les néo nazis et les limites de la
tolérance démocratique
jean françois kahn moulinex la
difficulté d'être une femme gré lice
sont portés par denise bauer showbiz et
sport la dernière mode
le disco sur patins à roulettes mais là
messieurs bonsoir n'eurent ou pas mûres
depuis 1848 depuis un discours célèbre
de victor hugo devant l'assemblée
nationale de l'époque les français se
demandent périodiquement s'ils sont
prêts à aborder de front le douloureux
problème de la peine de mort depuis 130
ans ils disent non et s'ils ne le disent
pas leurs dirigeants le dise pour eux
résultat la france est devenue l'un des
derniers pays à ne pas avoir aboli la
peine capitale
mais aujourd'hui il se passe quelque
chose dans une semaine on a vu et
entendu les réflexions successives d'un
groupe d'une dizaine de députés en
majorité rpr qui demande la pollution
pure et simple
le oui de françois mitterrand celui de
georges marchais l'interrogation
prudente du garde des sceaux et depuis
hier soir un feu orange du premier
ministre raymond barre comme beaucoup de
français n'a pas de réponse tranchée sur
la question
partagé entre ses convictions morales et
sa responsabilité politique
mais il n'est pas opposé à l'ouverture
d'un large débat au parlement à
l'automne
ce qui est important les français je
vous dis d'agir soir sont toujours
hostile à l'abolition
mais le camp des partisans a pris de
l'importance c'est ce que nous révéler
un sondage figaro sofres 58% pour la
peine de mort trente et un français sont
préoccupés par la violence qu'ils ont
raison et ils considèrent dans leur
grande majorité et sur ce point je ne
suis pas en accord avec eux que la peine
de mort est à des moyens efficaces de
lutter contre cette violence de faire
reculer la violence
nous sommes un certain nombre à penser
que c'est une idée reçue que ça ne
correspond pas à la réalité et je crois
que dans certains problèmes de
conscience comme celui ci il ne veut pas
hésité
aller à contre-courant à prendre des
positions qui ne correspondent pas à la
position de la majorité de l'opinion
tant que premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste je pourrais vous rappeler que
j'ai je suis signataire du programme de
mon parti et du programme commun de la
gauche qui prévoit une façon peut-être
un peu intemporel le l'abolition de la
peine de mort ce rappel est nécessaire
à titre personnel en conscience et c'est
bien un problème de conscience
oui de la vôtre sur cette question je
suis convaincu que le parti communiste
oui il va respecter l'engagement qu'il
avait pris dans son propre programme et
dans le programme commun de la gauche
nous sommes opposés à la peine de mort
et nous voterons donc tout projet
supprimant la peine de mort
personnellement je vous donne je suis
contre la peine de mort alors je trouve
que le vieil le vieux précepte tu ne
tueras point est un précepte
d'application générale mais nous vivons
en société et il peut y avoir des
situations dans lesquelles la peine de
mort est nécessaire pour sanctionner des
arcs qui sont profondément répréhensible
et qui soulève une réprobation générale
et n'est pas si simple les esprits sont
certes des passionnés mais cela tient
peut-être une actualité sans drame en ce
moment tout à l'heure un député udf
gilbert gantier à lui proposer la peine
de mort pour les auteurs d' enlèvement
de mineurs
nous connaissons pratiquement toutes les
argumentations du pour et des contres au
nom de la morale de la religion ou de
l'exemplarité aussi avons-nous préféré
placer le débat à un autre niveau à
l'aide d'un philosophe au prestige
reconnu par tous cela dit myriam keldych
qui parle donc de l'avènement je crois
qu'elle repose sur les principes tout à
fait sûr années et notamment sur l'idée
que le
la peine de mort et fasse le trim que le
sens que l'on verse un conte en
exécutant quelqu'un rachète le sang qui
a été versée par le criminel comme s'il
y avait un rapport entre l'un et l'autre
le temps qui coule dans le même sens de
l'humour et irréversiblement fait que
vous ajoutez un crime à d'autres crimes
une mort un meurtre un autre meurtre
meurtre il est pas un crime évidemment
une exécution capitale
vous ajoutez donc le sang versé vous
sang versé sans leur acheter le moins du
monde
l'idée même du rachat est une idée
inintelligible quand il s'agit de ces
choses là
est ce que cette option personnel
souffre d exception naturellement elle
en souffre beaucoup et notamment
il faut distinguer le temps de paix le
temps de guerre ce que je réprouve
c'est la peine de mort la peine légale
la mort légale en temps de paix
la mort légale c'était l'idée que l'état
ait le droit que l'autorité suprême les
autorités civiles et le droit d'enlever
à l'homme la vie en temps de paix c'est
un droit donc les théologiens dont je ne
suis pas je ne parle pas le langage des
théologiens général diront que seul dieu
à ce droit
ce dieu donne la vie et peut l'enlever
mais l'état n'a pas le droit de
l'enlever il peut mettre quelqu'un en
prison mais n'ont pas enlevé la vie de
quelqu'un c'est qui est sacré donc à ce
point de vue là je pense que l'état est
investi d'une autorité mystique en
quelque sorte magique comme la magie qui
veut que le sang versé rachète le sang
versé est mort les assassins d'enfants
les criminels de guerre enfin comment
comment est-ce qu'on peut régler ces
sortes de questions cette même horrible
elle hurle mon site horrible et j'ai en
moi également
à l'instar de vengeance très
compréhensible très naturel et je les
trouve par rapport naturellement
criminel de guerre n'est pas aux pigeons
qui ont commis des crimes monstrueux qui
sont pas même même pas à l'échelle
humaine et je suis d'avis dans ces
cas-là de fermer les yeux
laisser exécuter c'est contraire à mes
principes mais évidemment tout ça est
décousu l'irrationnel parce que l'action
est irrationnelle parce que le monde où
nous vivons une amende décousu et que je
n'allais pas tu aurais mme de géométrie
mais encore une fois je le répète rien
et monolithique dans ce dossier nous
n'avons pas le droit d'imposer notre
opinion quelle qu'elle soit d'ailleurs
cette rédaction est composée comme
toutes les sociétés d'individus et c'est
à chacun d'entre nous de se déterminer
tout à l'heure entre journalistes nous
avons eu un autre débat fallait-il ou
non vous projetez le sujet qui va venir
je vous explique les east ont depuis
quelque temps un relatif regain du
nazisme
il ya eu cette réunion les néonazis le
week-end dernier dans un château de la
région parisienne réunion évité de
justesse
il y a eu aussi de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique une manifestation de ces
nostalgiques d'hitler il ya un mois et
demi
manifestation qui va encore trouver un
prolongement dimanche prochain à chicago
jake séguy a rencontré là bas
l'un de ces néo nazis ces propos sont
datés blessant pour l'esprit pour le
coeur mais nous avons tout de même
décidé de vous les faire écouter les
voici donc avec tous les ondes chokr le
parti nazi a pignon sur rue à chicago il
suffit d'ouvrir l'annuaire son adresse
figure 25-19 ouest 71e rue fait les
américains s'interrogent
est ce qu'il est possible d'interdire un
parti qui se propose par exemple de se
rendre dans un des quartiers de chicago
sopi où habitent près de quarante mille
juifs dont 7000 ancien déporté la
constitution le premier amendement
permet à tout américain de proclamer et
de défendre ses sites et villes à
chicago une centaine de milles pour
l'ensemble des états unis
mais tous ne défilent pas sous l'oeil de
la caméra de cette façon cela dans un
quartier limitrophe de chicago entre
noirs et blancs aussi pauvre les uns que
les autres
cela se réclament de leur premier chef
leurs chimères un pouvoir totalement
bleu leur principal ennemi est donc le
noir premiers concurrents sur le marché
de l'emploi
c'est leur maître à penser est non et
leon n'est pas notre chef
mais il est le premier guide avoir
combattu le communisme en allemagne et
la france affronte le même problème
aujourd'hui et elle devra faire quelque
chose trouvez-vous l'action d'hitler oui
il celle qu'on a vue notamment dans le
film sur les transports locaux stv non
je ne pense pas que ce que nous a
montrée le fis n'est pas claire n'a
jamais donné l'ordre d'exterminer les
juifs mais celui des commissaires qui
occupaient les villes rouen tracé
l'ordre était de tuer les quatre sièges
la plupart de ses commissaires étaient
juifs
malheureusement howell série de chutes à
madrid
sinon discret le jamais eu la preuve de
la vérité et de l'évidence et ces
exterminations paraît donc posé le
problème de la liberté d'expression
démocratie au nom de la démocratie
peut-on tout dire tout montrer peut-on
aussi rééditer comme vient de le faire
un éditeur donc mein kampf sans la
moindre réserve comme le souhaitait le
président de la ligue internationale
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme et
bien
la réponse n'est pas évident à jean
françois kahn au fond le problème est de
savoir si une pensée ou une idéologie
est directement au sens juridique du
terme responsables des crimes que l'on
commet en son nom par exemple faut-il
que ce livre mike ans peut-il être en
vente libre dans les magasins alors si
vous voulez il ya deux écoles il y en a
qui disent écoutez d'un côté il y à un
citoyen est clair qu'ils avaient une
pensée il a développé dans un livre elle
est choquante certes mais il y avait des
milliers de livres en circulation qui
véhiculent des idées choquant
et puis de l'autre côté il y à un
chancelier du reich qui a commis des
crimes contre l'humanité
celui-là le monstre il devait être mis
hors la loi il devait être mis hors
d'état de nuire
mais la pensée du citoyen d'hitler doit
bénéficier de la même liberté que
n'importe quel autre pensée voilà ce
qu'ils disent et puis y en a d'autres
qui disent au contraire les atrocités de
hitler ne sont que la mise en acte de la
pensée dit plaire si hitler était un
monstre c'est parce que ces idées était
monstrueuse
autrement dit ce livre est bien celle
arme du crime
alors voilà au fond les les deux thèses
personnellement j'aurais tendance à
penser qu'effectivement une idée une
pensée un livre n'est jamais innocent
des crimes des forfaits que l'on commet
en son nom par exemple la pensée raciste
n'est pas innocente des massacres
raciste seulement c'est compliqué parce
que la pensée stalinienne et livres de
staline sont-ils innocent du goulag
le problème se pose et je voudrais
simplement pour finir vous rappeler que
les élèves du baccalauréat il y a trois
jours ont eu à plancher sur cette
question peut-on exercer sa liberté sans
prendre les risques
j'ajoute qu'un certain nombre
d'organisations syndicales et politiques
ont demandé l'interdiction d'un meeting
qui doit se tenir mardi prochain à paris
et qui doit réunir plusieurs mouvements
européens de droite et d'extrême droite
politique maintenant un nouveau
parlementaire en mission il s'agit
d'andré rossi député de l'aisne qui sera
chargé d'étudier le développement des
activités radiophoniques française au
proche orient
les sénateurs adoptent à leur tour le
projet de loi renforçant le monopole en
matière de radio et télévision avec un
amendement
c'est une amnistie pour les actes de
pirateries entre guillemets et commis
avant la date d'aujourd'hui les députés
eux ont adopté ce matin à l'aube le
projet de loi sur l'épargné et les
entreprises
puis quelques heures plus tôt le
gouvernement décidé de rendre effective
vous savez la hausse du prix de
l'essence
je rappelle donc que depuis minuit
l'ordinaire est à 2 francs 48 et le
super à 2 francs 68 le dossier social
maintenant avec d'abord la deuxième
grande réunion patronat-syndicats
aujourd'hui autour du thème de
l'aménagement est temps de travail se
pare d'un thèmes abstraits
regardez ce que ça donne quand les
horaires et les temps sont bien adaptés
star portage de jacques merino pas une
fabrique vendéenne de meubles les hommes
des machines des produits bref une ligne
comme des milliers d'autres
à ceci près qu'ici depuis deux ans et
demi une expérience originale de gestion
temps de travail est mené à l'origine
une constatation simple pour des causes
diverses pannes d'électricité tempête ou
autre il fallait parfois à rattraper le
temps perdu et travailler le samedi
matin ce qui n'est pas très agréable ou
encore parfois à quelques jours fériés
venait d organiser la semaine
alors qu'un grand pont aurait été
souhaitée et puis une troisième raison
des salariés qui fabrique ici des
meubles comme tous les salariés du monde
ont besoin de temps à autre de congé
pour convenance personnelle pour ces
trois raisons un accord d'entreprise a
été signé il prévoit que l'on
travaillera 44 eur 15 par semaine mais
que l'on ne sera payé que 43 eur 15
l'heure ainsi épargner est comptabilisée
pour former un crédit d'heures alors
nous avons des jours de congés sans nous
en rendre
combien d'heures d'avant s'avère
cependant actuellement nous sommes à peu
près stabilisés rapport à une semaine en
début mai une semaine de congé
supplémentaire que nous a permis scène
il avait pris toute la semaine du 1er
mai la semaine complète mais c'est à
dire trois jours il y avait déjà deux
jours de répondre lorsque nous a permis
la semaine entière mais si les syndicats
ici ont signé cet accord
il reste prudent sur l'extension de la
formule pour nous on en tire un bilan
qui est quand même positif sur le plan
d'entreprise ou alors pour nous
vous dit pas quand même qu'il faut le
reprendre pour l'instant sur le plan
national contenu de la revendication qui
est fait par le cnpf sur le plan
national des discussions par rapport aux
10 noeuds précisément le cpm a proposé
un budget annuel une propose un budget
annuel de 19 120 heures réparties par
rapport aux besoins qu'ont les
entreprises par rapport à la demande de
travail pour nous et tout à fait
pourquoi on préfère avoir d'abord
premièrement avoir un horaire régulier
parce que ça correspond quand même
voire moins de fatigue pour le personnel
qui est beaucoup plus facile de vivre
dans cet esprit-là que
le vivent comme ça à parakou sans savoir
quelles sont les horaires de débauche où
une embauche à longueur de l'année ce
crédit d'heures et comptabilisé ateliers
par atelier il est géré sur ordinateur
et figure sur la feuille de paye une
limite toutefois à ce système les
avances du retard en temps de travail ne
peuvent pas dépasser plus ou moins 15
heures nous pensons que cette variation
pourrait certainement être doublé
peut-être même triplé ceci évidemment en
fonction des impératifs autonomie est ce
qu est pensable qu'un jour vous
travaillez 15h les pendant les périodes
de faible et 45 heures ou 5 en terre les
périodes fortes dans ça je crois
franchement que ce serait du rêve
je ne vois mal une usine insoumise un
tel régime ça ne serait pas possible je
ne crois pas les systèmes qui a ses
avantages et ses inconvénients
avantage pour l'employeur lui garantit
de gestion et un absentéisme plus faible
pour le salarié un salaire plus régulier
plus de souplesse dans les horaires et
des peaux plus facile inconvénient un
alourdissement de la gestion des
salaires mais ici tous s'accordent à
reconnaître les avantages l'emportent
chose inconvénients ono maintenant
travail normal aujourd'hui dans toutes
les usines indique la direction qui n'a
toujours pas pris de décision à propos
des neuf mille ouvriers a mise en
chômage technique depuis mardi
boussac nouvelle manifestation
aujourd'hui mais dans les vosges
plusieurs dizaines d'ouvriers ont barré
la route nationale 57 près de 20 c'est
de thaon les vosges
ils réclamaient le versement de leurs
salaires du mois de juin et il y a eu
vous l'imaginez de sérieux
embouteillages notamment chez les poids
lourds
chez moulinex maintenant la direction
annonce que l' usine d'alençon sera
rouverte lundi et que le travail pourra
alors reprendre
la situation demeure inchangée dans les
autres usines du groupe ont voulu
essayer de comprendre comment les femmes
d'alençon vivaient leur grève elles sont
en effet 50% sur l'entreprise qui compte
un peu moins de 3000 ouvriers et déjà
elle avait fait parler d'elle il ya
quelques années
denise boere a donc qu'on fait c'est
marie-claude 28 ans employée l'a vécu
alors c'est ou c'était la grosse presse
normalement et à quelques petites
machines où l'on découpe simplement des
pièces c'est l'hallu puis je sais plus
quoi comme matière quoi ensuite vu
qu'avant j'étais vendeuse
ça fait tellement de bruit que je
demandais à mon avis de cet atelier très
rapidement et ont envoyé sur chaîne
alors la seule chaîne donc j'ai fait de
montages du contrôle l'emballage enfin
je fais un peu tous les postes aussi et
ils voient que vous n'avez pratiquement
pas de temps de pause pendant la journée
oui alors il ya juste le temps pour
aller aux toilettes
c'est à dire sept minutes avant 9 heures
le matin sept minutes après et là
prémunit aussi c'est le seul temps
effacé vraiment contrôler ainsi la fille
est trop longtemps on se fait engueuler
y contrevient quoi vous veniez combien
dans man au bout de huit ans de maison
2900 francs je fais fin je regrette un
peu je suis sympathisant plutôt aux
syndicats et chez moi ça pose des
problèmes parce que mon mari ben mhenni
pas du tout pour ce faire il ya des
réunions quelques francs tort quand même
du travail
surmontant mois personnel et enfin il
n'aime pas ce à quoi et je vois qu'il ya
beaucoup de camarades autour de moi qui
ne se syndiquent pas parce que
premièrement seul après ses problèmes et
ses veillées mari ne pas faire le
réunion non plus fort bien qu'ils
avaient des ghosts cagliari ne veulent
pas garder les gosses
en ce moment nous prenez en grève ont le
cul plus zine et là on voit qu'on a
toujours des problèmes puisqu'il est
mort lui-même qui viennent chercher les
fermes faut des fois le soir on demande
des volontaires pour faire le piquet de
grève
c'est pareil et personne enfin il y en a
quand même et quelques femmes qui
voudraient bien dire qu'il peut faire
à quoi est-ce que votre avis la grève
est la seule solution pour que les
femmes se fassent entendre dans une
entreprise comme celle là oui parce que
jusqu'ici on voulait des réunions cdp
seul essieu cce et on n'obtient rien du
tout toujours pour voir ça la prochaine
réunion
alors il n'y a pas de solution reportage
de dennis blair sncf le service banlieue
sera perturbé ce week-end dans les
seules gares de paris est et de paris
lyon à la suite d'un mouvement de grève
des conducteurs autonomes le dossier des
micros du canard enchaîné va être
réouvert devant les juges damien lui
lacère vieille de quatre ans et demi
la cour de cassation annule non lieu
prononcé par la chambre d'accusation de
paris jamais les policiers qui avaient
installé le système des coudes dans ce
journal n'avait pu être entendu
une petite phrase dans l'humanité de ce
matin signé roland leroy le directeur
les dirigeants socialistes sentent le
sol se dérober sous leurs pieds qu'elle
témoigne bien du mauvais esprit
les relations pc ps en ce moment que
nous améliorerons certainement pas les
propos de françois mitterrand hier à
rennes en ce mitterrand avait dit que la
tentation du pcc telle alliance avec la
droite autrement dit le compromis ce
tank
alors pourquoi cette nouvelle attaque
noël godin mais je dirais que c'est un
peu la réponse du berger à la bergère le
parti communiste accusé le parti
socialiste de renoncer à l'union de la
gauche et de ceux et de virer à droite
le parti socialiste lui réplique en
disant que le parti communiste lui même
renoncé lion de la gauche est prêt à
passer un compromis avec la droite
il faut rappeler ce qu'est le compromis
storey le compromis historique
l'expression nous vient d'italie
disons qu'elle symbolise précisément
l'entente du parti communiste avec des
partis de droite et du centre avec
informel de différence c'est que en
italie parti socialiste n'est pas
d'accord oui et soul et c'est là
précisément que se situe le problème
c'est que le parti socialiste français a
eu une inquiétude craint dans cette
affaire de se faire en quelque sorte
court circuiter il a je crois cette
inquiétude depuis que le parti
socialiste depuis que le parti
communiste avait lancé son slogan union
du peuple de france
un peu après les élections
présidentielles de 1974 alors qu'est ce
qui permet à france à mi temps de faire
cette hypothèse succès je crois que
l'analyse de françois mitterrand du
parti socialiste repose sur le fait que
le parti communiste a un langage qui se
situe à plusieurs niveaux
il y a le langage de la lutte de classe
et le niveau du parti communiste parti
la classe ouvrière
il ya le langage de l'union de la gauche
c'est en gros le niveau du programme
commun et puis il ya le langage de
l'union du peuple de france et le niveau
d'une vaste coalition qui n'exclurait
selon le parti communiste que la petite
caste de ceux qui dominent l'état et
l'économie pour le parti communiste n'y
a pas de contradiction entre ces trois
niveaux de langage le parti communiste
passent des accords avec les autres
partis de gauche et appelle d'autres
parties à venir renforcer cette union
par contre pour le parti socialiste ces
trois langages correspondent à trois
stratégies qui seraient différentes
le repli sur soi l'union de la gauche et
l'union du peuple de france ou compromis
historique et il ya contradiction pour
le parti socialiste entre les deux
dernières stratégies union du peuple de
france et union de la gauche dans la
mesure où l'union de la gauche
disparaîtrait seraient dilués dans cette
union du peuple de france ou compromis
historique qui n'aurait plus de
consistance politique et dans laquelle
le parti communiste serait le centre et
serait le parti dominant nous cette
attitude de refus de condamnation de
suspicion nouvelle étape finalement de
la mésentente et de la politique la
politique étrangère maintenant avec les
d'abord depuis quelques minutes un dîner
de travail entre helmut schmidt et
valéry giscard d'estaing près de
hambourg ce n'est pas un sommet franco
allemand mais une occasion pour les deux
hommes d'échanger des idées à quelques
jours de grandes rencontres
internationales
c'est dans cet endroit discret aux
environs de hambourg que les deux hommes
d'état se retrouvent donc une fois de
plus pour des entretiens informels comme
ils en ont pris l'habitude au centre de
l'entretien la crise
pour y faire face comment harmoniser les
violents et pas seulement entre paris et
bonn mais aussi entre les pays membres
du marché commun
comment introduire un peu plus de
discipline dans les fluctuations de leur
monnaie ces entretiens prépare les
réunions au sommet qui se tiendront le
mois prochain en allemagne fédérale est
donc l'objectif le plus important est
d'obtenir que les états unis acceptent
enfin de participer un rééquilibrage
économique en luttant un peu plus contre
l'inflation
nouveau bilan à salonique qu'à l'issue
du tremblement de terre qui a ravagé le
nord de la grèce mardi 48 morts turin
après senteurs de libération la cour
d'assises a prononcé 29 condamnations
contre des membres des brigades rouges
la peine la plus lourde est allé à
renato curcio le chef historique des
terroristes italiens 15 ans de prison
seize autres inculpés ont été acquittés
une réunion sur le cancer aujourd'hui à
paris thème cancer chimie hérédité nous
sommes entourés par des milliers
d'agents cancérigènes et pourtant nous
ne sommes pas tous concernés
alors martine alario s'étend maintenant
pourquoi mais alors je vous dis que nous
sommes tous cancer est la réalité
mais nous savons très bien lutter contre
les cellules cancéreuses que nous
fabriquons en permanence nous avons 70
mille milliards de cellules qui mute qui
sont agressés qui se transforme nous
avons quatre systèmes de réparation qui
nous permettent de les rendre sociale et
de le remettre dans un organisme normal
alors ça c'est la bonne situation
deuxième constatation 80 90 % des
cancers sont liés à l'environnement
alors c'est la rencontre entre un
terrain nous qui luttons qui nous
défendons qui nous transformons et puis
des agents extérieurs
alors je vous ai pris un exemple ici
c'est tout à fait théorique
vous avez là une barre que j'appelle le
cancer visible ainsi vont tout à fait
théorique
je vous ai pris quatre personnes pierre
paul mari jean je prends un agent
cancérigène et je vais choisir le tabac
fait un peu d'éducation en même temps si
vous fumez 20 cigarettes un même taux
pour tout le monde
vous avez toutes les chances d'avoir le
tabac qui agit sur vos systèmes et qui
vous permet de répondre en réparant
transformant en créant plus ou moins de
goudron et en les éliminant plus ou
moins bien alors si c'est pierre s'il
fume 26 grèce il va avoir quand même une
chance d'aller vers le cancer qui va
être comme ça mais ce n'est pas terrible
en face à l'italie signac le tabac mais
celui-là paul ray un cancer du poumon
marine aux gens non plus maintenant si
vous prenez un autre agent vous allez
découvrir que paul et résistant et que
pierre ne l'est pas parce que ça marche
pour un agent il y en a dix mises en
circulation
est-ce qu'on a un moyen de ça
à quel niveau alors voilà alors ça c'est
le grand mystère car il sent qu'il y ait
aussi 10000 facteurs pour répondre aux
agents cancérigènes pour les intégrer
dans notre patrimoine héréditaire
alors ça c'est la grande inconnue ça
s'appelle l'hérédité le terrain et je
crois que nous pouvons pas dans
l'immédiat après les chercheurs de
l'inserm que j'ai fait ce matin disent
que nous ne pouvons pas savoir qu'il n'y
ait plus prédisposés que tel autre
attelage en mai ils répondent deux
choses d'abord l'environnement et plein
de choses cancérigènes les sites sans
signe des virus des radiations et ça on
peut tout de même faire de la prévention
en les supprimant ou en les éliminant
des nôtres changer complètement le tabac
et le tabac l'alimentation fumée en
excès comme dans certains pays
en islande les radiations en se
protégeant il ya tout de même dix mille
moyens alors pour l'airé dit et j'aurais
quand même me prévenir tout de suite
nous ne sommes pas les uns prédisposés
au cancer et d'autre part nous sommes
prédisposé aux résistants à un agent
donné nous avons toutes les chances
d'avoir un jour un agent quelque part où
toutes les chances de résister une
nouvelle fièvre du samedi soir est en
train de secouer les états unis il y
avait le discours ses terres la musique
sur laquelle tout le monde danse ils y
avaient leurs rollers borde le roller
skate sur le patin à roulettes
il ne restait plus qu'à les réunir ces
faits et s'adonnent les disco roller ce
des patineurs sur fond musical
pour être gagné par cette nouvelle
fièvre deux conditions à remplir
avoir le sens du rythme et le sens de
l'équipe ensuite comme pour les six
jours cyclistes on tourne tourne autour
de la piste et puis on rêve on est john
wayne ou du moins d'abord nous sommes
avons cru à une demi-heure des buildings
de manhattan
mais la nouvelle rumeur de new york dit
qu'il se passe des choses étranges sur
une piste de détenus
le rythme avec les pieds
et parfois le
et cette libération du corps et de l'âme
s'appelle tout simplement le roller
disco
tout
tout de suite en excitant comme rodez
des bruits plus excitant sexuellement
parlant
pardon vous ne sauriez pas john travolta
par hasard non vous ne seriez pas
italien bien sûr que je suis italien
regardez comme je danse
oh
à moins j'ai fait ça parce que je veux
devenir une star le godet toi ainsi
parle pas de quatre aspirants à la
gloire
et vous aussi vous voulez devenir une
vedette
non pas du tout on fait ça parce que ça
m'amuse
trad de confidences dabo tête
la voici pour nom des nues
je tenais quel sens du rythme ce mini
lumineux c'est ce que deviendra bini les
en revanche le roller skating disco à
brooklyn
ça roule je parlais il ya des phénomènes
vacances à travers la presse le nouvel
observateur à paraître public toute une
enquête sur la grande folie des
résidences secondaires en cyclisme et
bien c'est le belge willems qui a
remporté le tour de suisse avant de
terminer le journal la météo
comme chaque soir des nuages des averses
et un temps frais c'était le lot de la
france d'aujourd'hui que vous découvrez
un peu derrière moi demain pluie sur la
manche et en montagne avec même de la
neige au dessus de 15 100 m ailleurs un
temps variable
seules les régions méditerranéennes
bénéficiant voyez d'un petit peu de
soleil pour dimanche maintenant
persistance du temps frais avec tout de
même davantage éclaircies notamment sur
l'intérieur dernier journal ce soir
22h45 de la trouverez pierre-alain
n'oubliez pas demain samedi ennemis
consacrée à l'amour en herbe thème de
l'émission de jean claude mongeau la
sexualité chez les jeunes je vous
souhaite une excellente fin de semaine
et je vous retrouverai avec un très
grand plaisir lundi
bonne soirée à tous